ambiance studieuse en salle des séances
pour les élus du conseil départemental
des jeunes des collégiens venus de toute
la côte d'or
ils ont entre 11 et 15 ans et déjà une
certaine idée de l'europe c'est l'union
ça me fait penser à l'union c'est un
ensemble de pays uni qui disent tu es
qui défendent la même cause être unis ça
permet de collaborer tous ensemble et ça
montre un bel esprit à la tribune des
étudiants de sciences po
les conseillers départementaux juniors
vont pouvoir échanger avec eux sur
différents thèmes
ici par exemple on parlait europe et de
développement durable concernant les
transports
qu'est ce qu'on pourrait faire le
transport des voitures hybrides
ma plus de transports en commun la chez
les jeunes élus les idées fusent on sait
à l'agriculture aussi ne pas trop
construit des villes sur les campagnes
mais tu penses vraiment que c'est à
l'europe de régler ce problème là bah
oui vu que tous les pays sont réunis
ensemble ils doivent tous se mettre
d'accord il faut se sentir européen il
faut avoir une conscience européenne et
au delà
l'inscription qui assure notre passeport
de la nationalité européenne c'est des
vrais une nouvelle conscience collective
et je pense que j'espère en tout cas
qu'on leur a transmis sa aujourd'hui
parce que c'est eux le futur
cette session extraordinaire s'est
terminée par la lecture d'une longue
motion rédigée par les conseillers
juniors pour une europe en résumé plus
proche plus forte et plus verte
le texte a évidemment été adopté à
l'unanimité